[Music]
this
is star talk i'm neil degrasse tyson
your personal astrophysicist
and for today's episode we're talking
about
the covet 19 vaccines
chuck you with me on this one i am
indeed
however i am not vaccinated you're not
vaccinated okay
and and i'm i'm halfway through that so
did you
did it up at harlem hospital um up in
manhattan
uh in harlem of course uh so obviously
neither you or i have specific expertise
in this field so we go into our man
who does and that is dr erwin redliner a
friend
for many decades irwin welcome back to
star talk
now i i i so delight in reading your
title
because it's the one of the baddest ass
titles that we've got here
so you are the founding director of
columbia university's
national center for disaster
preparedness wait and you created the
pandemic
resource and response initiative at
columbia university so this is you're
the you are the man
if i ever see a disaster i'm running to
erwin
we're going to think of you help me dr
redlinger
if you see a disaster don't call me i'll
be really offended
but when godzilla comes we're calling
you yeah no matter what happened
so really we're here to um
by the way the uh you you have a long
history
of the medical treatment of children who
couldn't otherwise afford
that treatment and your author of the
book i have to give this a shout out
the future of us what the dreams of
children
mean to 21st century america wow so
you're the man thank you for for even
agreeing to be on our on our podcast my
great pleasure actually
neil and hopefully and we got we got
chuck here to make
jokes so nothing you do is a joke
so check exactly
yeah so we'll we'll try we'll see how
this goes i don't know
[Laughter]
i called dr redlener a hour
our own tony fauci like you know we got
our own person
we don't need we don't need tony we got
we got
erwin redliner you know what i mean
that's that's where we are
so so let me just ask you the the
vaccine
you know i view it like any other
vaccine if it can prevent an illness i'm
getting it
but there seems to be this gurgling of
attitude towards the vaccine holding
aside the
regular variety of anti-vaxxers okay
there's like a new subset
or or are there maybe they're not new
maybe it's old who
have specific objections to this this
vaccine can you
tell us what's different about this
vaccine from others yeah and i thought
about this a lot neil you know
one of the things was remember when it
was introduced it was introduced during
one of the
strangest most bizarre
presidential administrations in american
history that is
under the umbrella of donald trump so
almost
anything that was introduced in that
weird four-year span
was viewed with skepticism and
uh doubt and you know when he would say
for example
that we're going to fast-track this and
he had something called operation warp
speed which he actually did
have people either didn't believe it
they were skeptical about it
and it was a new technology this sort of
uh this so-called
mrna the messenger rna technology
so this was born in an environment
of serious skepticism also at a time
simultaneously near where where
the anti-vax movement was growing anyway
so it was into this kind of perfect very
complex
situation where people have doubt and if
it's fast-tracked does that mean
they they bypass the safety
assessment that we normally would expect
i mean the fastest vaccine ever
developed before this was
the mumps which was a four-year process
most vaccines take well more than 10
years so
there was skepticism all right so what
you're saying is we were
a victim in a sense the vaccine movement
was a victim
of of the cry wolf problem right
because if so much of what emerges in
the trump administration
was not objectively was not connected to
an objective reality
and then he says something that is then
the entire anti-trump movement
it has justifiable skepticism that it's
going to be correct when
in fact in this case it was it was
correct so
perhaps we shouldn't just in general we
shouldn't be getting our medical advice
from elected politicians a very good
point
think about this he says inject yourself
with bleach
to cure yourself of covid and get a
vaccine
do you know i forgot about that okay
all right so it's fascinating that it
happened in this perfect storm of
misinformation
and but what about the integrity of
institutions right if nasa says an
asteroid's coming
people are gonna listen all right so
certain institutions
have an integrity that has been
preserved or at least
fared better than other institutions you
mean like the cdc
yeah for example the cdc or any other
sort of medical
the you know the mayo clinic what
whatever it is
yeah that we trust are we in a post
institutional trust error forget an
individual how about just institutions
well here's here's what happened with
that so within a month
of the recognition that we're dealing
with a pandemic
based on this particular coronavirus the
cdc
sends out a hundred test kits across the
united states for people
and laboratories to be able to test to
see if one has a covenant or not
those test kits one third of them failed
so the cdc stepped out of the gate
with a very unusual demonstration of
that immediately eroded the public sense
of
faith in the cdc as an institution to
your point
so again this is like you said it's this
kind of
collision course of incompetencies
disbelief
uh dishonesty etc and here we go and we
should not be surprised that people are
you know skeptical about the vaccines
holding aside the
the scarcity and you want the medical
professionals to be first in line yeah
but wasn't there some also some
widespread
statements from authorities declaring
that masks are not helpful
there were there absolutely weren't in
fact tony fauci himself
was not all that enthusiastic about mass
early on and that changed
obviously but um yeah there was a lot of
rumbling
and uh grumbling and people making
statements that were not necessarily
true
or things that they probably should have
said we think they are but we'll see
we'll be test doing a lot of tests and
experiments and observations
there's a larger point i want to make
about that but let me keep moving this
forward what about
um the distrust of big pharma
that's out there that's real that's um
and and the people who might be all
in on their mistrust uh if you sift
through that there's gonna be some
things in their mistrust that yeah that
actually did happen
yeah there is the profit motive so how
do you address
that dimension of of this misinformation
you know let me say this in 1947 and i'm
making a point here
the country was worried about a
a new influx of smallpox
into our country
new york city called up the six
pharmaceutical manufacturers that made
vaccines they ordered six million doses
they didn't have to check with the state
and they didn't have to check the
federal government they just
the city the city to the new york city
the mayor
and the that's badass yeah it's totally
badass man this is like
yeah we need six million doses we need
it now they got six million doses and
in less than six weeks they inoculated
for smallpox
six million new yorkers and
the pictures are astounding there's new
yorkers lined up for blocks and blocks
you know these kind of
40s images of black and white images it
was amazing
people trusted the health commissioner
and the mayor
they said there was a bad thing coming
this small box go get vaccinated
and they did in droves now we've had in
the
60 years since a gradual increase in
absolute skepticism
about institutions about corporations
about uh
government and all this has now you know
it's all congealed
in this massive mistrust of everything
including the institutions that we
should be trusting
one good thing a good thing about the
binding administration
is the restoration of trust is happening
already and it's happening
much faster than i even anticipated deal
okay so now what about this idea that
you're unlike other vaccines where you
put
sort of a denuded version of the of the
virus
and your body thinks it's the full virus
yeah but but you don't get the disease
but you get the antibodies
so that's the more traditional
understanding
of yeah of of vaccines this one
is actually modifying dna
and that's kind of has a spooky feeling
to it well rna for the
for the pfizers and the and the
modernist and dna
for the new j johnson johnson that's
coming up but yes it is spooky
and it's actually the the so-called mrna
the messenger rna vaccines
are actually tricking the body's cells
into thinking that they've been invaded
by
some foreign virus when they're in fact
been
been tricked into thinking that there's
a protein because of a protein
that's inserted into the body they're
tricked into thinking that it's
some sort of uh external virus and then
they manufacture the antibodies
so there's genetic engineering this is
genetic engineering
it is genetic engineering wow yeah wow
what's this
great okay
you're not changing my dna right you're
not
engineering me you know well you kind of
are we're making your body think
something
is happening to it that isn't that
that's but but neil we do the same thing
with the old style viruses we
let's say if we give a dead uh different
kind of like what's called an adenovirus
uh a dead or uh attenuated
version of the actual virus you're also
tricking the body into thinking that oh
i got i got a real enemy here i'm going
to mount
a an immune response and okay you know
this is what vaccines do okay so it's
just it's a more sophisticated
version of what we've been doing what
we've been doing yeah
for our bodies for decades yes that
that's a fair way to say that then
well okay so this is also a a cosmic
queries
and we did solicit questions from our
fan base
um on the vaccines and
so i'd i'm curious let's oh by the way
one last
point the trust or mistrust of vaccines
does not
land equally in the demographics
of this country or even perhaps the
world
and i think that may be rooted in a
distrust of
organized medicine all right and let's
look at sort of the black community
for example uh just there is some
really ugly history there and
so there's got there's a there's some
explaining that needs to happen
there's some really significant effort
in the restoration of trust
that's necessary i'm not letting the
government do no experiments on me
right well exactly exactly so so can you
could you just remind us
of sort of the pinnacle of the source of
this distrust
yeah so there's a particular pinpoint
in history that
happened in the 30s and 40s which was
called the
tuskegee experiments where researchers
legitimate scientific medical
researchers
decided you know we'd like to figure out
what happens to somebody who gets
syphilis
and we don't treat them so they rounded
up a bunch of
men with syphilis black men in tuskegee
and said you know we're going to give
you free medical care
and we want to just observe you over the
next few decades to see how you're doing
they did not tell them they were denying
treatment
for syphilis so over the decades they
learned what happens with untreated
syphilis
at the cost of the lives and health
of a large number of black
americans so the point is there were
treatment was available if not cure they
believed they were getting treated but
they were just getting a placebo
and there they were unwitting medical
experiments yeah horrendous
i i i like to use the term nazi-like i
mean you know
i i and i mean that in a in a particular
way because
normal people don't experiment on other
people like that it's not
okay in any way but the bigger thing too
but what was the organization that did
it was it the university it was medical
government
yeah it was university researchers okay
and i think those government involvement
government funding okay yeah the
eugenics movement was still
sort of in progress in the early
thirties when that was very important
but you know this is also on top of a
few hundred years
of slavery of jim crow of institutional
racism
this was like the kappa this was the
this is a very explicit horrendous
experiment
on top of mistreatment and
of uh african americans we confirmed
this there was the public health service
in collaboration with the tuskegee
institute doing these experiments right
right so it was a government funding
okay and it went through the 60s into
the early
70s so it's multi decades so so
what why would you expect
anybody to believe anything you're
saying when we have that kind of history
that's the question and this is what the
challenge now is
how do we embrace what actually happened
and move on from that at a time when
it's
critically important that black
americans
brown americans native americans
must get vaccinated and one of the
things to neil is they are
those populations are particularly prone
to catching the disease dying from
disease and getting hospitalized from
the disease
so they are the highest risk groups who
have the most
hesitancy about getting the vaccine and
this is
this is going to be tough work
convincing people that they really do
need to get the vaccine in spite of that
history and i have the answer
i i figured it out what's it what's the
answer
it's called the racial buddy system for
vaccination
[Laughter]
any black person that goes to be
vaccinated a white person must go along
with them
and they must get vaccinated from the
same vial okay
the white the white person goes first
like a
food taster like a food taster oh the
black person
it's just like all right here's my white
buddy he goes first
bang if you can be killing black people
gonna be killing white people right
alongside
all right we got to take a quick break
when we come back we will indeed get to
our
questions from our fan base on
the covet vaccine what's it all about
when star talk returns
we're back tyson here i got chuck nice
tweeting at chuck nice comic thank you
sir all right chuck i'd like i'd love
your tweets they're
they're insightful and i'd laugh most of
the time some
they look like you're experimenting on
us with whether something is funny
well listen i'm i'm very much like the
public health service of comedy
experimenting on our twitter is your
sample base
is okay
so we're talking about the cobit vaccine
um all
all nuances of it with our friend of
star talk
dr irwin redliner who's chief honcho of
all
disaster preparedness that we know of in
this country
so uh er we've got questions from our
audience if you don't mind taking them
chuck you've got them lined up what do
you have chuck i got them right here
so let's start things off these are from
our patreon patrons and of course if you
are listening to this feel free to go to
patreon.comtalkradio support
us and uh we will give you
um priority so to speak okay
uh hey neil hey dr redliner i was
recently
listening to an episode of who who who
asked this
uh this is still cameron bishop cameron
bishop okay yes
uh he says i was recently listening to a
star talk epic
uh episode about pandemics years ago
which had to be laurie garrett lori
garrett for sure
uh he says i was curious the guest said
that
back when we no longer have to vaccinate
for smallpox
it's because we eliminated
the virus how likely is something like
this
with sarv's covid2 please stay healthy
and uh there you have it okay excellent
question i love it
so so irwin so sarge kovid ii that's the
the official
that's the the geeky name for the for
the coveted 19. yeah sars ko v
dash 2. okay so that's the name of the
virus is the
specific virus and the disease you get
from that is covert 19.
right a fair way to put that okay it is
okay and the reason it's called cov2
is because we had a cov1 back in 2003
in fact which is when people started
thinking about how we're going to
confront it
with vaccines and so on okay but i
thought it was covert 19 because it was
2019 when it was discovered
yes but the name that's the disease but
the name of the virus
is sars hyphen c o
capital v uh hyphen ii two so it's the
second
virus it's the second virus in this
family of one
family viruses got it got it okay all
right
perhaps you know my father besides kobe
1.
we call them big dog big dog kobe
that's what you call my dad you shot him
down in tombstone arizona and i come for
my
[Laughter]
prepare to die
all right so so what so if smallpox is
done
then what can we have similar hopes for
this one
no because damn
can't okay next question
yeah all right yeah yeah yeah go ahead
no
it's the the problem is that it's a very
these coronaviruses which is this
this is one of are very very common you
can't really eliminate them and it's
going to end up being
endemic meaning around all the time it
may well get
mixed the the vaccine for this may well
get mixed into the annual flu shots
that we get and that's that will control
it
but i don't think we're going to stop it
unfortunately
isn't it true equally as important is
that
humans homo sapiens were the only
victim of smallpox so if you get rid of
smallpox it's not
jumping to you from a bat or from some
other creature that we handle
that is correct okay so smallpox head
was unique in that way now if you're
going to have species jumping viruses
uh you it's not clear that you would
ever be able to stamp them out entirely
at all
correct and then you have also the the
so-called variants or mutations that
we're confronting
where you have a little bit of a change
in the
makeup of the virus that causes it to
have different characteristics or less
sensitive to the vaccines and so on so
this is going to be around for a while
but i think we'll learn to live with it
and we'll adapt to it but uh
it's not going away like smallpox yeah
and like you said if
it's a part of every season's cocktail
then yeah we're good to go all right
here we are all right all right chuck
next question excellent
okay let's go to toby sonnenberg who
says
hello from new jersey we're
so sorry for you i know what i just
thought
but first of all chuck lives in new
jersey so that's just
a joke that's why i can say it's a joke
you could say it's a joke
but also just the way you said that i
was ready for it to be from a really
exotic place
all right it's like toby from you know
exactly
from tasmania no from new jersey
okay yeah yeah yeah go ahead uh toby
says this
why couldn't pfizer and moderner
start uh using standard vaccine
techniques for covet 19 why was it
necessary
to use the rna vaccine
uh so there you have it yeah so wouldn't
it have been easier just to
just to denature the virus we already
know is in the house
and then so what
why is one faster than the other well
maybe but you know
the the mrna technique
is really quick and it's very effective
and you're not fooling around putting uh
live or attenuated vaccines uh viruses
into people
so there are a lot of advantages even
now because you know
now we're seeing all these variants and
mutations we're worried about
them being more effective and maybe uh
more lethal
you can make a very rapidly a booster
shot let's say in fact moderna is as we
speak
working on booster shots that will
specifically address these new variants
uh otherwise we would have had to start
from start fresh in a very
different and much more prolonged
process
uh to get the the uh protection uh if we
were using the old techniques
erwin you used a word uh infective is
that the same thing as contagious
it is in the context of how we're
talking about yes that's the same thing
okay
okay so is it also not true that because
a lot of people are
somewhat concerned that this technology
if you will call it this advancement
uh was rushed but is it not true that
this has been in the works for quite
some time because
of some people uh after the sars
outbreak saw the opportunity
to make these advancements and through
these
hedge fund investments started working
on this years ago
so it's not like last february
they started working on this mrna
technology
exactly that's exactly correct and like
we're just talking about before
uh chuck it's it's actually started as
you just reminded us
uh after the stars the initial stars uh
pandemic and uh yeah and we had a real
running start
getting prepared to rapidly develop the
vaccines that are confronting the sarge
kov2 virus
and that's a dimension of this entire
landscape that i think is
unrecognized or unappreciated that that
it was a running start up to the
starting
to the starting line yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right chuck keep it coming
come here let's keep going i love these
let's go with fernando
gomes uh or gomez
i'm not sure he says uh why
do our policies fail so badly
in enforcing mass vaccinations
since it is a collective protection
measure shouldn't
everybody partake irwin let me just
jump before you answer that uh is there
some renewed sense of individual freedom
that people feel the need to express in
this country
so that the idea of being free means
i don't have to listen to anybody tell
me anything
yeah actually that's a really big
problem of course
again exacerbated by donald j trump
who made a political uh
agenda from this public health
catastrophe and which here's the thing
about this so
it's a question of i'm i'm deciding to
take a risk
and you don't have a right to tell me
not to
except that's not really applicable if
you're risk-taking means that you're
going to climb up a
you know straight wall cliff or go
skydiving
good luck to you and we'll let you do
that insurance and in this country we
let you do that
yes you can do that but if your risk
puts threatens me that's not okay
you can't you can't say my risk is
i'm not going to wear a mask let's say
that's i'm taking that risk uh
so i'll get kovi uh starscopy too and
and
that's my choice it is not your choice
because your choice
is actually if you implement it if you
do what you say you're going to do which
is not
do the protections that are required and
you make me
or my family or my friends sick
because of your recklessness that you
are declaring your personal
right that is not okay in a society like
ours so it's a
it's differentiating between the
individual risk
and taking a risk on behalf of a lot of
other people okay so the people who are
now
doing that did they just not learn
civics did they just not
uh are they have no empathy are they
i mean you're a medical doctor with
presumably some training in psychology
or psychiatry how do you analyze this
it's it's a little narcissistic it's a
little self-centered
it's it's about focusing in a very
egotistical way
on you personally with uh some
disregard for your the people who are
around you and i
i think that's that's really what we're
talking about and that could get
obviously extreme which doesn't happen
all that often but people
uh who who say who have no empathy
whatsoever and they sort of were
drifting into the realm of
psychopathology and that's not okay but
for most people who are in that category
i don't think they're thinking properly
or broadly about
what they are implying when they say i'm
taking this risk
and you be damned and that's that's
where we
run into trouble or it could
very well be that those people
are anal apertures better known as
a-holes okay so that's explained the
whole thing there you go
okay do i have to answer that
no you don't have to ever steep as low
as chuck goes okay this is not a
requirement
so chuck give me one i've got time for
another a couple more before this
segment ends
okay here we go this is woody what he
doesn't give us anything except he's
woody
and he says uh what level of efficacy
uh what different groups have receiving
the first round of vaccines
how does preventing spreaders like youth
compare to protecting the vulnerable
like
uh oldies um shout out to australia's
corona cast for the idea
well wait so is it okay are those two
different questions like one of them is
what is the let me split that what is
the efficacy
of the very first round of experiments
that are conducted
right if you're going to say it's safe
for me because
you experimented on some other humans
what is that about
so i think what he's asking is exactly
what you just said but he wants to
use the first round as a means of
comparing and contrasting the
efficacy between the elderly
and young people instead of just trying
to protect
certain people yeah so let me let me say
so first of all
the long history of uh medical research
and the use of human subjects was
originally
about uh the subjects being
you know middle-class middle-aged white
males
and many many experiments to figure out
what drugs work and so on
were done with that very narrow group
and then people sort of say well
what about women what about african
americans what about children
and i think our understanding of if
you're going to do a broad-based
full population vaccine for example
uh you can't say that you if you gave it
to
ten thousand white guys uh that will
definitely
middle age white guys that'll definitely
be uh effective in
older people or african-americans or
kids
so so the more demographics are that you
have to address
the bigger that original sample has to
be exactly right
exactly right and um so when people say
are we going to give the vaccine to
children for instance
um and dr falchi recently said yeah well
probably in the fall we'll be starting
to give it to children as young as six
years of age
which is probably fine but then they're
gonna have to before that
give a lot of young children the vaccine
to make sure it's safe and effective
which is ethically a little tough as you
can imagine right because plus a child
is not unlike an adult a child is not
entirely accountable for having received
the
trial dose of vaccine in the first place
right nobody could give you
a trial of anything without your
permission and that without getting a
whole lot of explanation
of the risks and the benefits etc but
what is it that you're supposed to say
to a seven-year-old
to make that person you know comfortable
or have the ability to
give approval oh it's so so easy
so easy here's some cookies and some
juice
the answer will be yes
no no here's a lollipop okay i'll take
it i'm going to take a quick break
our final break and when we return it's
to the covet vaccine
and dr erwin redliner we'll see in a
moment
we're back star talk the covet vaccine
chuck we're in we're in question mode
for erwin redliner let's give me some
more all right
let's keep it moving let's go with roman
prick up
who says hi doctors okay well thanks for
leaving me out
did you feel that as a disc chuck no i
mean
i mean you know i'm i'm the only one
that's not a doctor here
he could have said hell doctors plus
chuck he could have said that
you know all right you know we're fine
we're finally getting our doom deal
all right he says hi doctors uh do the
current vaccines
really decrease the spreading
or just make the symptoms
less severe so yeah so the vaccine
people
are they spreaders and they don't and
they don't but they don't get it what
well they might be
and unfortunately we didn't set up the
trials
well enough to know or appropriately
enough to know the answer to that
question but what we do know
is that they're very effective in
preventing
disease serious disease and
hospitalizations all of them are
including the new
uh johnson johnson vaccine which will be
out in uh you know a month or so
so that's what we know and uh
the degree of spreading unclear
it's unknown it's a it's pure and simple
okay yeah
right right so that would mean you could
be a carrier with no symptoms
is what that comes down to yeah okay got
it okay
keep it going chuck all right let's keep
it going sam couch would like to know
this
what makes certain vaccines have the
requirement of being stored
under super cold temperatures well while
others
have no issue being stored close to room
temperature irwin i was looking at the
temperature for the pfizer vaccine
70 below zero come on now
excuse me okay ninety
seven you're gonna ruin the vacuum
so you're not going to have the corner
vaccine dispenser
doing this this is going to have to only
be in major institutions and hospitals
that have freezers that long yeah
of course so so yeah what what's up with
that
so pfizer requires about minus 90
fahrenheit
modern about minus five the new johnson
and johnson
single-dose vaccine will be able to be
stored for three months
in a regular refrigerator wow which is
an amazing
advance and even though the the j
vaccine is said to be less effective
it still is a an incredible vaccine when
it comes to preventing
serious illness and hospitalizations but
the big problem here
really the big problem is the global
impact
of of trying to deal with vaccines that
need this sort of
arctic temperature uh for containment
and storage
so we will not be able to use
the pfizer vaccine for example in many
many developing countries where
that's called the cold chain that cold
chain capacity does not exist
so i think so it may be that your less
effective vaccine
which stays preserved in a refrigerator
will in fact be the most
effective force fighting
absolutely because that will have the
widest distribution
right and by the way if we don't address
covid
19 in every single country on earth
it really will will affect our ability
to get this virus under control
in general so we can't say oh we're
doing great in the u.s
and in you know 90 other countries we're
not doing so great because those will
become
pockets for infecting mutating
and causing resurgence of the uh cova-19
disease so
we have a lot of global work to do which
is why the j and j
vaccine is so critically important part
of our armamentarium
that's the first positive thing i've
heard about it so it's good to good to
to realize this yeah people saying for
sure yeah in fact on on late night
comedians were poking fun if they were
third
in the list and they ended the 50 rather
than 95 percent
and so yeah it didn't look good it's
like
a laggard student in your class you know
yeah except that it doesn't have to be
stored
at you know um moonlight temperatures
yeah you know all right give me some
more chuck
here we go this is matthew power
uh matt powell we should collect all the
names that would be great superheroes
from our fans
yeah so matt power wants to know this he
says
uh hello dr redlener dr tyson it's my
understanding
that two at least two vaccines by
different companies
are on the market are these vaccines
basically the same thing
are they so different that it makes a
difference
hmm is he talking about you think the
j j versus the f i know we just
i guess how about just the two rna ones
he's talking about the two
that are pretty much the same so that's
moderna
and yeah yeah yeah there's not enough
difference to talk about with those
you know um i've been vaccinated my
wife's vaccinated
at the same place she got pfizer i got
moderna
um you know are it's just
they're they're close enough in the way
they function
uh we're very confident in the results
and the safety of both of them uh there
are some
differences in how they're manufactured
which account for why they
require different temperatures for
storage you know like i said minus 90
for pfizer minus five
for uh moderna but you know
if you're worrying about which to get
don't worry about it take whatever's
available
yeah get get it get it that's the lesson
yeah what you get right okay all right
this is
mike bertruccio mike bertruccio wants to
know this hello
what advancements to vaccines in general
were developed for the covet 19 vaccine
do you anticipate that we'll see new
vaccines coming onto the market for
other diseases i like that yeah so did
was this a leap
in any way uh irwin it was definitely a
leap
but uh again i think we should mention
once again that this was not a leap that
happened you know a year ago
the leaping began at least as far back
as 2003 when people were looking at
new mechanisms for developing vaccines
and came up with this
so-called mrna technique
but also in the last 20 years there's
been great
advancements in medical tools and
technology to even accomplish this isn't
that correct
yes no question about it okay and um
yeah and this this advancement is
occurring non-stop and we will certainly
be getting things that we can't even
imagine now this is one of the things
the beauty of looking into the future
is that the research the developments
the innovation doesn't stop
like in other areas of science this is a
an iterative process
we learned this last year way what if we
modify it this way what will we get or
what if we have a whole
new vision of how to make a vaccine and
uh and that's what's happening by the
way i want to say one other word that's
really important to the discussion of
vaccines
the new tool that we'll have in our
toolbox
will be medications that you can take
as an outpatient if you have the early
signs of covid
and you test positive for it where the
doctor can prescribe
a new medication you take by mouth and
you're done with it
so that the combination of the vaccines
as they get more effective and more
distributed
and new medications to actually treat
the early forms of disease
is what's going to allow us to gain
control over this
terrible pandemic and that's the light
at the end of the tunnel really both of
these things
cool very cool so you do have something
positive to say
mr disaster preparedness person okay
okay
i do you know one of the radio shows
that i'm on a lot
stephanie miller's show they call me dr
doom doctor doom there you go
which is good anyway
no comment all right all right keep
going chuck we got time for
like two more questions go all right
let's uh
let's go to josh v josh v
says you know he don't trust you with
his last name that's right i know he
does he's
clearly uh just one person i am not
trusting chuck
i don't blame him
[Laughter]
all right josh b says this i read a lot
about herd
immunity and the numbers of immune
people
needed to defeat the virus is
is there clarity on what percentage of
the population needs to be
vaccinated to actually achieve
herd immunity isn't that dependent on
how close we ever are to each other
on average isn't hurt immunity different
for
for rural and that it is for urban
not so much when we talk about whole
populations really so
in any community any community
will need to get a certain number of
people have either had the disease or
who are vaccinated
with an appropriate immune response so
that number
was once thought to be 65 to 70 percent
of the population had to have the
immunity
it's now well into the 85 90 that must
have it
and um that's that's a a
hard row here to hoe here and uh we're
gonna
see what happens but it's a lot higher
number or percentage than we thought
so the way that hurt immunity works then
correct me if i'm wrong
is you're one in ten that has the
disease but nine of us
can't get it because we're vaccinated so
you're not going to spread it
and so what are the chances of you
finding someone else who
is one in ten well that's sufficiently
low
correct that even if you do spread it
that person has to have sufficiently low
likelihood of something happen as well
so it
rapidly tamps down back to zero exactly
exactly that's the whole point all right
so that just shouldn't say so
i know we're running out of time but i
just want to follow that up with
when you said what you said initially
was
enough people either have to be
vaccinated or
get the disease so with that in mind
we are now seeing some cases i don't
know if they're isolated or not but
we're seeing some cases of
re-infection does that change
the whole uh prosperity concept of
immunity at all
yeah yeah now well the thing of it is a
tiny number of cases or reinfected cases
and you know this is weird thing
happening that people have had the
disease
documented and presumably have the
antibodies
to uh to saurus kov2
are still getting vaccinated so uh
my son by the way who had documented
um covet 19 in march
last you know last march uh
recovered had antibodies he still his
doctors wanted to get
the vaccine which he's getting so
small chance but really small okay chuck
what
we got 30 seconds give me something okay
hello neil hello dr redlener as the
virus continues to mutate and become
more immune to vaccine that's an
assumption he's making
how often do you think we'd have to
vaccinate to maintain
life from all the mutations of kovic ooh
i like that
oh look at that i do too but we don't
know
we don't know sorry who wants to end the
segment with
i don't know no no i got another way to
come in on that
but just to to shed a little bit of
light on that are you saying
there's not something sufficiently in
common
with all of the mutations that
by attacking that thing they have in
common it'll get any mutation that could
ever
take place you're telling me you're not
in that situation no we're not in that
situation damn
you know i thought you guys weren't like
the conversion is like you know
dangerous and it may be more lethal than
other ones and we just
it's a work in progress and viruses are
smart they're wily
they'll figure out a way around whatever
we put there so we have to be very
careful
and very diligent in addressing it could
you end up making a super virus by
trying to attack a virus
all i know is all i'm telling you is
that
viruses mutate like crazy and we got new
mutations by the way in the united
states right now
um and uh
we just have to stay ahead of it this is
why we have to get everyone vaccinated
as quickly as possible so that the
mutations don't run wild right because
the more viruses there are out there the
more
opportunity there is to mutate so yeah
right so the idea is we all have to do
what we're supposed to do which is our
part in getting vaccinated yes
and if you're not vaccinated then you
have to do your part by
washing your hands and wearing your mask
and then after you get vaccinated you
still got to wash your hands and wear
your mask and all that
so basically every everybody's
responsible
life is cool life is cool damn so i just
want to sort of
conclude by noting that i think
something needs to be updated in our
educational system for people to
recognize
that anything that's scientifically new
will have uncertainties
and but the best access
to what is good for you will not come
from people who are not the scientists
all right the scientists will find out
on that frontier
what is working what is not and if at
any given moment you got to jump in you
can jump in
but if things change it doesn't mean the
scientists don't know what the hell
they're talking about
it means at that time that was the known
understanding
and you and that comes with a risk so
the press generally doesn't talk about
that risk they just say
the scientists don't know anything and
that is because it hasn't been taught
in a way where people can understand the
actual
undulating moving frontier of discovery
and so i applaud your candor when you
said we don't know
yet whether after your vaccine if you
can spread it
we don't know that that is so important
and it's not a sign of weakness it's a
sign of this is how the science works
and stay with me on that this is what
you've been teaching
everybody forever which is that this is
the beauty of science we
we learn this there's more to learn we
keep learning it's
it's constant exploration yes yes and
that's a beautiful thing and that's what
we have to teach in school
this is this is how we know and and
learn to know
we got it so finally we got irwin to end
on a good but a positive note
there you go that's right and i'm
encouraged i'm encouraged because if not
knowing makes science beautiful then i'm
the most beautiful scientist there it is
all right chuck
chuck on that one all right irwin always
good to have you thanks for being a
friend of the show
uh chuck you know i love you love you
too all right neil degrasse tyson here
concluding our episode of the covert 19
vaccine as always i bid you to keep
looking up